sudan's prime minister has resigned
following months of political turmoil
abdullah doc said it was not possible
for him to restore order under a power
sharing agreement with the military
after the army staged a coup last year
hamdock was reinstated to head up a
transition back to civilian government
[Music]
another weekend of protest in sudan
that quickly descended into violence
at least two people were killed by
security forces
after thousands of pro-democracy
demonstrators took to the streets
[Applause]
dozens have died in the unrest since
prime minister abdullah hamdok
signed a power-sharing deal with the
military following a coup in october
but he now admits that hasn't worked out
and new thinking is needed
[Music]
i decided to give back the
responsibility
and announce my resignation as prime
minister
to give a chance to another man or woman
of this noble country
to continue leading our dear nation
and help it pass through what's left of
the transitional period to a civilian
democratic country
military and civilian leaders have been
sharing power
since the autocrat omar al-bashir was
ousted in 2019
after 30 years in charge
elections are currently planned for july
[Applause]
but with hamdock gone
and sudan roiled by unrest
the road to democracy
looks increasingly fragile
earlier today i spoke to khalid khair
she's managing the managing director of
the think tank inside strategy partners
and i asked her why hamdock decided to
step down now
i think he came to realize just how
unpopular his agreement with burhan on
the 21st of november was he had expected
that this agreement would effectively
end the coup and would give him powers
to be able to set the transition back on
course but of course as soon as the coup
happened this was no longer a transition
and the military showed that it wasn't
um the good faith actor that it was
expected to be and in any case people
had reservations about the extent to
which it was a partnership in the first
place
and so really he was unable to work um
beyond beyond the
these last few days he sent to which the
military was willing to return to the
violent oppression and suppression of
protesters we saw before this government
took shape
so what does this resignation now mean
for sudan
well anyone who comes in now as a prime
minister would be drinking from the same
poison chalice anyone any new pm would
be seen as an accomplice to the coup
much in the way that uh hamduck
relatedly came to be seen but also like
hamtuk they would also have very little
executive space within to function they
wouldn't be able to choose their own
cabinet they wouldn't be able to make
their appointments they wouldn't be able
to undo appointments made by the coup
regime and so it's unlikely that anyone
will want to want to step forward and
anyone who at least who genuinely wants
um democratic transformation who wants
to step forward now into handover shoes
what makes far more sense is to restart
the um
the
the sort of transition and find a new
political agreement a new political
basis and a new constitutional basis
that actually pays attention to what the
resistance committees the people on the
streets the pro-democracy forces have
been saying and not just sort of find
ways to divide up um political places
for uh political parties which is very
much what we saw in 2019 this time
around there has to be an agreement that
more people can buy into and it will
genuinely be process driven rather than
just oriented around you know political
structures
will be lots of fighting over who gets
what position
from inside strategy partners in
khartoum thank you very much for your
insight
you